you've got you you've got mail
you've got you've you've got mail
goodbye to all of you who thought aol
was voiced by a computer
now let's set the record straight i
recorded those phrases welcome
you've got mail
files done
goodbye
my name is elwood edwards and i'm the
voice of you've got mail
in
1989 my wife was a customer service rep
for the company that was about to become
america online
she heard steve case talking to some of
the programmers about how fun it would
be to add a voice to the software
i've been an announcer throughout my
entire broadcasting career
and she volunteered me
i scribbled those phrases on a piece of
paper and like i say on the cassette
deck i recorded the welcome you've got
mail files done goodbye
it started off as a test just to see if
it would catch on and lo and behold in
the mid 90s it had really caught on and
at one point they said my voice was
heard more than 35 million times a day
but the problem was i was typecast the
one thing i did do was a voice for the
simpsons
you've got leprosy literacy
goodbye being associated with aol has
been gratifying
even today you go on aol.com
i greet you i greet myself
[Music]
you know what this is the wagon the
river dying of dysentery all you ever
wanted to do is get to willamette valley
safely it's the oregon trail but did you
know that this iconic game started as a
board game
it was 1971. three guys don bill and
paul were roommates in minnesota they
were student teachers
don who would often dress up as
historical figures to captivate his
students needed a creative way to teach
lessons about the oregon trail
so he created a board game he started by
using a map of the american frontier and
wrote flash cards for the hardships
pioneers faced like dysentery broken
wagon wheels and snake bites
as soon as his roommates got wind of the
board game they suggested he pump it up
by turning it into a computer game over
the next two weeks the three men put
together the very first version of
oregon trail but small problem they
didn't have a computer so they used this
wacky machine a teletype a sort of
glorified typewriter that didn't even
have a monitor basically they would type
code onto these huge pieces of paper and
then print them out
when the program was done dawn's class
couldn't get enough of the game kids
were staying late and arriving early
just so they could play oregon trail
several years later don got a job with
the minnesota educational computing
consortium an educational software
company and he pitched them oregon trail
as a program idea as soon as apple 2s
were launched in the late 70s and sent
out to classrooms all over minnesota
oregon trail became a big hit such a big
hit that other states began licensing
the game and the rest as they say is
history
[Music]
conjunction junction
what's your function
hooking up two box cars and making them
function
conjunction junction
that's one of my most popular songs huh
conjunction junction
in 1971 bob durow oh that's bob hi
someone asked him let's put the
multiplication tables to rock music and
we'll call it multiplication rock what
do you think
[Music]
and so this happened schoolhouse rock
and it ran for 64 episodes
yes
the songs were iconic and many of them
were written and performed by bob
well i can't say exactly how many i
wrote for schoolhouse rock but
i'd say about 22 and a half
but bob's career isn't limited to
schoolhouse rock nope
i'm a producer even an actor karoo sold
us out man he tried to hang that shut up
guard singer pianist
and uh
all-round good guy he played with miles
davis deep down he was a sweetheart
bob's been writing and recording music
for over 50 years but he agrees that
despite all this i'm probably best known
for the job i did for school house rock
it was total fun
when you have a
commission that makes it easier than
just to say write me a love song okay
well where do i start but you know put
the multiplication tables to
music and make it
3
interesting
9
12 15 18. it was easy
[Music]
369.
[Music]
i've been the voice of mario for 26
years now moving on to luigi now moving
on to louis
[Music]
hi i'm charles martinez i do the voice
of super mario here we go woohoo
and i was even donkey kong at one point
i am an actor and voice actor i did uh
gosh 25 years of theater run along to
your party corporate videos circuitry
and semiconductor processes a few film
and television products now beat it all
of you now and then i had the marvelous
beginning of becoming a voice actor and
that's how i started with uh itami mario
mario was first created in 1981 in a
game called donkey kong as it got
refined through the years uh it became
mario and and princess peach
[Music]
and uh i came along in 1990 i actually
crashed an audition because i was
catching them as if i walked in they
were walking out finished for the day i
said can i read for this and the guy
looked at his watch and he goes ah all
right come on in you're an italian
plumber from brooklyn a character in a
video game for nintendo called mario so
make up a voice make up a video game
start talking and i thought to myself
video game i don't know anything about
video games and all of a sudden i hear
action i go hello i'm a mario let's make
a pizza pie together you go get some
sausage i'm gonna get some spaghetti we
put spaghetti in the sausage and pizza
and he said you know cut stop talking
there's no more tape all right thanks
we'll be in touch and i thought that was
you know okay there's the door we'll see
you later and i he calls nintendo i
found a mario i got him and that was 26
amazing fantastic years ago
hello hello
oh look at this world
the character for me brings out the best
in me and so i i love that
i love sharing things too i go to meet
uh mario fans and i hear the most
wonderful thing you know you're the
voice of my childhood or i you know i
used to play with my dad now i'm playing
with my kids you know and we just it's
the way our family comes
pretty
together
ah this brings back the memories
you just have fun you know that's my
mantra for life come on let's go let's
have more fun bye bye see you in my
games is woohoo
[Music]
fox you probably remember this prolific
90s fad but what you may not know is
that pogs have roots that go all the way
back to 17th century japan
okay first things first let's review the
rules to play you start with a stack of
pogs all face down player one takes a
slammer and throws it down into the pile
and keeps any and all pogs that land
face up pogs that remain face down are
restacked and the game continues on the
player with the most pogs at the end of
the game wins hooray
the origins of pogs can be traced back
to this menko a classic japanese game
players threw cards at their opponent's
cards with the goal of flipping them
over in the early 1900s japanese
immigrants settled in hawaii and brought
the game with them
over time it evolved into a version
played with milk and juice caps from a
local dairy company in maui eventually
renaming it pogs after their juice that
was made out of passion fruit orange and
guava get it in 1991 this woman a 6th
grade teacher named blossom galbiso
introduced the game to her class her
goal was to teach them math but in a fun
way and it worked big time kids loved it
and the game exploded in popularity
throughout hawaii and then spread to the
mainland as the game took off this
marketing guy alan rapinski took note he
purchased the trademark for pogs founded
the world pog federation and got them
into every store in america
and subsequently into nearly every home
with a 90s kid
thanks alan
[Music]
it was the game that coined a dozen
catchphrases
and made over a billion dollars in
quarters
but i mean jam almost never saw the
light of day
oh my he's on fire
[Music]
this is nba jam game designer mark
termell so we put together a demo a
video tape vhs we sent it to the nba and
said hey we're making this cool game and
they immediately shut it down and said
no we don't want the nba logo in the
arcades so once we got rejected uh we
made a video tape of nice family
entertainment centers and we sent that
back to them and said look you know this
your logo can be here so they relented
and uh provided the license
when we put it in the arcade for the
very first time there were no stats that
differentiated the players everybody
assumed that shaq was a bad three-point
shooter or stockton could steal the ball
so we realized pretty quickly that we
had to you know up our game
to match the real world
well if it's just looking at pure
attributes i happen to be the best
player in the game
when you actually put in my secret
character it just shows question marks
for the stats but they're all tens or
nines
from the outside
i'm pretty good at nba
to test the claim we had mark hack into
the machine
there we go and turn on cheat codes all
right now we're talking
[Music]
usually when somebody finds out that
i've made nba jam they say i spend so
much money on that nba jam or you know i
flunked a class in college because of
nba jam
well i look at the game now i wish it
were smoother but it was the technology
at the time
the game still holds up today
[Music]
you